[Music]
[Music]
i didn't read this by the way he's like
nothing
that is true that is true clap you
people
laugh like you're an audience
and not some assorted employees i
dragged in here happy tuesday everyone
so how was your valentine's day cat said
she spent the night in cuffs
well if the atf had their way she could
have spent it in jail as well i get it
the bureau of alcohol tobacco firearms
and explosives tweeted a plea to
disgruntled exes to share info on former
lovers involved in illegal activity
valentine's day can still be fun even if
you broke up do you have information
about a former or current partner
involved in illegal activity
let us know and we will make sure it's a
valentine's day to remember
now you know that i am a law and order
guy
not the show that sucks
i mean the real thing
but this creeps me out mainly because
you never want to rely on bitter exes
for anything
she or he could call 9-1-1 and say
you're holed up in a basement with an
arsenal larger than the cinema sinaloa
sounds right yeah cartel and hip-hop
awards combined
when really yes when really you're just
eating pizza in your underwear we call
that the ducey
anyway we've actually obtained the first
few phone calls to the atf
atf what's your emergency my wife she's
being erratic she's drunk and she's
doing arts and crafts okay calm down
does she have a gun yes she's using it
to stick rhinestones everywhere okay sir
that's a hot glue gun please hang up
wait wait wait um
she also has a van full of ammonium
nitrate parked outside joanne fabrics ah
we're on our way awesome thanks
atf what's your emergency hi yes my
husband is acting crazy is there alcohol
or tobacco involved no are there
firearms well he just watched all the
dirty harry movies and i'm pretty sure
he's about to start john wick keep him
where he is we'll be right there
atf what's your emergency my boyfriend
left for work and he's being such a jerk
are there weapons or contraband in the
house no i'm by myself just me and my
bikini
ma'am you're aware you called the bureau
of alcohol tobacco and firearms oh i
love a man in uniform i'm just so lonely
are you lonely
so there's no gun present i thought
maybe you could bring yours
i need the long arm of the law oh boy
i'll uh i'll be right over
there you go
nice one so yeah like a drug sniffing
datsun this won't catch criminals what's
next starting a fight at the
thanksgiving table to see which one of
your relatives is strapped
and we all know snitches get stitches
martha has that tattooed on her ankle
so look it was a cute idea but it helps
no one especially christina yuna lee she
was murdered by a homeless fiend talk
about a hard right turn he allegedly
stabbed her 40 times after following her
into a chinatown apartment early sunday
the killer you already know the drill
living in a shelter because there's no
place for the criminally deranged they
should have tried getting him a job as a
cnn producer
he had dozens of arrests and was just
busted on january 6th but freed
unsupervised release yeah supervised
release
how does that work
unless that means a cop following this
psycho around 24 7 i don't want to hear
about it anymore because it doesn't work
at all
meanwhile actual january 6 2020
defendants weren't even given bail
so this guy's locked up he finally
figured out how to stay arrested murder
someone that's the bar now for inclusion
which coincidentally is the same bar
gangs like ms-13 use for initiation
because nothing else sticks in a
hellscape where felony assault and grand
larceny are like ripping off the tag
from a mattress
but hey if only one of the killer's exes
had seen the atf tweet who knew we could
have tricked him with a whitman sampler
or have his ex make a reservation at
applebee's and then slap the cuffs on
him during dessert
but what's the point of having people
knock on each other when you don't even
lock up the people you already busted
it's the cart before the police horse
maybe figure out how to keep these
monsters behind bars before you figure
out clever ways to grab more
if you need to figure this out just look
at what we did five years ago before
democrats screwed this up right now
heinous criminals roam like free-range
chicken and progressive da's hide from
the mayhem they caused no wonder they
love mask mandates i'd wear a mask too
if i were them these crimes keep
happening and what follows outrage
mostly on fox then it's forgotten rinse
blood and repeat
many victims are asian when will the
asian leaders who represent them do
something big creating a cupid's 1 800
crime line on valentin valentine's day
is not enough and forget platitudes
about stopping asian hate homeless thugs
don't read tweets from the mayor's
office it's up to you asian groups
because other groups just aren't that
into you there's no asian lives matter
group fighting on your behalf instead
they judge you as a group they're trying
to keep out of college and they call
that anti-racist and don't expect help
from the dems either they're literally
they literally doubt that women exist
hell aoc just blamed the crime surge on
the expired child tax credit
we don't want to say some of the things
that are that are obvious like gee the
child tax credit just ran out on
december 31st and now people are
stealing baby formula we don't want to
have that discussion
we want to say these people are
criminals or we want to talk about
people that are violent instead of
environments
of violence
and what we are doing to either
contribute or to dismantle that oh my
god
yeah that's what's causing all the smash
and grabs the carjackings the stabbings
what an ignorant statement
how does she not own at least a dozen
cats
actually these environments of violence
weren't so violent before loons like her
got into power and sorry lady we talk
about this stuff every day i'd ask where
you've been but we all know planning
trips to florida
we've talked to the victims families we
poured over the stats and so far not one
person was beaten to death for baby
formula in fact the people struggling in
this lockdown economy aren't stealing
baby formula at all they're wondering
why they're no longer safe on their way
home
aoc these victims aren't ideas or
political constructs these are women who
bleed to death when they are stabbed aoc
claimed her life was in danger because
of a riot in a building she wasn't even
in
but dismisses actual murder as a problem
over taxes
what's next her critics are sexually
frustrated
christina yuna lee wasn't butchered to
death over baby formula in an
environment of violence
she was a young asian woman followed to
her home where that became an
environment of violence that aoc and her
side helped create while living in a
safe make-believe abstract world
if they dusted the murder scene for
prince
they may not have found yours aoc but
your bad ideas were an accessory
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest
she's our favorite mccallum not named
single malt host of the story martha
mccallum
[Applause]
she's been in more locker rooms than
athlete's foot former nbc sportscaster
michelle tafoya
she's like a rake from home depot thin
pointy and face down in your yard fox
news contributor cat tips
and he uses a leaf blower to make a
salad my massive sidekick and the nwa
world television champion tyrus
michelle welcome to the show so happy to
have you thank you i am excited to be
here a fellow golden bear we're golden
bears well you know i sent my diploma
back so i'm not sure i'm still i still
have claim to that my husband told me
you know once you send that back you
can't say you graduated from the
university of california berkeley and i
said okay that's fine yeah so you have
regrets too
[Laughter]
from what i remember it wasn't very good
for me either you know we got to talk
about this aoc equation tax credit
baby form formula murder
i mean it's so simple why didn't we
figure this out she might as well have
learned that at cal but um you know that
that is uh
so bizarre but
i grapple with every time she speaks
because i ask myself why do we pay
attention to this woman but obviously
she gets tons of publicity because she's
a master at getting tons of publicity
true and people do need to respond to
some of the insanity she spews
one of the things that i i read that she
said was
the biggest thing that joe biden could
do right now the most important thing he
could do is forgive student debt right
and i'm sitting here thinking
that's the most important i mean this is
one of the headliners in this piece that
yeah you did with the new yorker so she
she's very off yes and she also said
that you know congress is a i'm allowed
to use the sh word right yeah
it's in deep or whatever she's yeah so
yeah it's been that way for a long time
she didn't help no she made it she
actually makes it work she thinks she's
above it she thinks she's above congress
and she lives in this kind of she lives
in an abstract collegiate world right
where none like all these practical
things and bad things that happen in the
world don't really affect her so she
makes these like it's definitely baby
formula martha it's definitely baby
formula it's so twisted how in what
world does this woman who represents new
york
not
bend over backwards to talk about this
woman who was followed six flights up
yes by this man who is deranged who has
been arrested i think 12 times in the
past several years and why isn't she
screaming from the rooftops that this
man should be in jail and protect this
young woman young beautiful new yorker
like herself who she apparently has you
know no affinity right right um or no
sympathy for she's blaming it on baby
formula apparently there's some racket
that was you know wiping baby formula
off the shelves and selling it on the
black market she and then she says you
know the problem is that we ignore the
reasons behind things yes she's ignoring
all the reasons behind things and
professing to know what's going on and
she she just obviously doesn't know
what's going on in either one of these
stories no it's amazing tyrus i really
want to know how you feel about the atf
x's narking story but if you'd like to
touch on the other ones you're more than
welcome but i have a feeling you have
strong feelings about that yeah i had uh
three visits from
the sheriff this week
a lot of stuff yes
there were no weapons of mass
destruction in my house
um so i mean that was nice but it was
the idea
to promote
not letting it go yes and to promote
stalking yes in the name of the law
is about as normal as someone saying to
aoc when she says gee let's have that
conversation
with a straight face go yeah let's do it
go yes because you're walking out of
that drooling and probably wetting
yourself with just the ridiculousness of
her comments they make no sense and i
think it's by design right how are you a
socialist but you're complaining about
how much money you get paid it doesn't
make sense it's like she's
either she's an evil genius
who's doing this for some other
crazy reason
or
nobody bothered to read the resume at
the bottom and i think a lot of people
who voted
are going to be have to be looking in
the mirror going
but she's got a future she had two
vowels in her nickname
you thought that meant that she had some
stuff behind it
[Laughter]
yeah there you go g
yeah g would have that g let's have that
conversation because no one talks about
crime nobody does no one talks about
baby powder yes well it's actually no
baby formula maybe four million no one
knows better than me greg
okay
okay
i once confused the two oh boy was that
embarrassing oh that's probably yeah
yeah you can't don't try to put on
leather pants with baby formula
right cats
excellent uh
voice work today on these skits thank
you yes yes do you know that the press
secretary i just found this before the
show said that the rise in violence is
because of hate-filled rhetoric and
language around the origins of the
pandemic we touched on this that somehow
like all these homeless dudes are upset
about asian people over the pandemic i
gotta be honest i never see them reading
no no like i don't think
i don't think that that's true yeah
yeah i i don't and if with aoc it's one
she's like not only did she say
something that was that ridiculous but
she's like nobody's talking about this
yes and sometimes the reason no one's
talking about something is because it's
dumb like it's not
it's not there's a reason nobody's
saying that but again she's not a
socialist she i always say this she's
not a socialist she has a french bulldog
right that does not exist without cat
this okay there's not a rescue no that's
not a rescue that's a defensive dog that
is made they don't even have they don't
have sex with each other they have to be
genetically engineered and then
c-sections because their heads are too
big that dog does not exist without
capitalism so all you need to do is look
at her dog to know she's full yeah the
other thing too and we're going to move
on
i believe every everything she gets is
from another person like somebody goes
did you hear that all of these things
are from baby formula and it's caused by
and she and then it goes into her brain
she goes and then she just spits it out
she hasn't thought about anything i can
really empathize with that but i'm not
in a position of power yeah well you
kind of are all right thanks
for kids who don't really really read
good yeah
no one's talking about it yes
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else